[Music]
yeah it's about to get real gross but
first let me explain this is carbon sink
Adi he's a competitive eater really he
placed second in last year's Nathan's
hot dog eating contest but for the
purposes of this video he represents
your smartphone and those wings
that's cellular data just loads of
gigabytes pouring into his mouth see
brother Jimmy is $20 all you can eat
wings deal is a lot like those unlimited
plans from Verizon AT&T Sprint and
t-mobile instead of buying a certain
amount of gigabytes a month say six
gigabytes the major carriers now want to
sell you unlimited data you pay a set
amount and you get as many wings
I mean gigabytes as you want sorta
that's where Carmen comes in just like
an all-you-can-eat restaurant deal
all-you-can-eat cellular plans only make
sense for some so before you fall for
the marketing hype here's what you
should consider
number one data digestion you need to
ask yourself how much data do you really
eat Carmen here eats a lot 115 wings in
one sitting really he did them that's
like the equivalent of say 50 gigabytes
a month he streams hours of Netflix
downloads big files and tethers his
laptop to his phone but what about the
average eater say I eat eight wings or
four gigabytes a month I email check
social media good amount stream music
but also spend a lot of time in places
with Wi-Fi Verizon is $85 a month beyond
unlimited plan makes sense for Carmen it
includes loads of LTE data unlimited
720p video streaming and 15 gigabytes of
mobile hotspot data but it might not
make as much sense for people like me
who have shared data family plans that
start at less than $60 a person number 2
unlimited limits say Carmen is eaten
through 22 gigabytes of data this month
in places where many people are heavily
using the network
carriers might slow down your speeds
depending on your plan and your usage
some of the unlimited plans also limit
video streaming to 480p or 720p
resolution instead of the 1080p quality
number three video bundles oh did I
forget to mention that this
all-you-can-eat wings do comes with all
you can drink draught beer the cellular
equivalent is a video service bundle
AT&T now includes watch TV with access
to 30 plus channels t-mobile includes
Netflix with two or more phone lines
sprint includes Hulu and Verizon
includes its comparatively lame bow 90
yes cellular carriers are pushing these
deals hard but it really comes down to
the all you can eat if you eat your
money's worth you win if you don't eat
your money's worth they rip it
[Music]